على الصعيد الخارجي وكما ذكرنا الغى
الرئيس جو بايدن زياره الى باب وغينيا
الجديده في المحيط الهادئ للقاء قاده جزر
المنطقه
والمشاركه في محادثات تتعلق بالامن
الاقليمي لمواجهه نفوذ الصينيه المتزايده
هناك اهميه زياره بابغينيا الجديده تاتي
لانها كانت ستكون اول زياره لرئيس امريكي
في منصبه لهذه الدوله كان من المقرر ان
تستمر زياره بايدن لثلاث ساعات فقط وتوقيع
اتفاقيات امنيه مع الدوله المضيفه ومع
مايكرو ناسيا وفي حال اتمام الزياره فهي
ستكون بعد عام من توقيع دوله اخرى في
المنطقه هي جزر سليمان اتفاقيه تعاون امني
مع الصين وحينها اعتبرت واشنطن ان
الاتفاقيه مع الصين ستكون لها تداعيات
امنيه اقليميه سلبيه زياره اخرى
ملغات هي لاستراليا حيث كان من المقرر ان
يلتقي بايدن بزعماء استراليا والهند
واليابان وهي قمه اخرى مخصصه لمواجهه
النفوذ الصيني نعود لقمه باب وغينيا
الجديده واشنطن بوست قالت ان قراره بايدن
سيثير تساؤلات حول مدى التزام الولايات
المتحده تجاه دول المحيط الهادئ في وقت
تتزايد فيه المنافسه بين الولايات المتحده
والصيني في المنطقه وكانت زياره بايدن
الملغات ستكون قصيره جدا لكن الاستعدادات
في العاصمه بورت مورس باي كانت جاريه لمده
سته اشهر واشنطن بوست نقلت عن محللين
قولهم ان الغاء او تاجيل الزياره سيعطي
زخما للقائلين ان الولايات المتحده ربما
تكون شريكا لا يمكن الاعتماد عليه على
المسرح العالمي واشار المحللون الى ان
اصلاح الضرر ممكن لكن على المدى القصير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات